well guys what started off as a pure
sideshow in the TP vs. faze clan lawsuit
has developed into a big story all its
own hi sky the underage streamer who was
recently suspended from twitch is back
but how did we get here and what happens
to hi sky if t Foos lawsuit actually
makes it to court
well it seems like the controversies
never stop for phase claim these days
now in this video I'm gonna talk about
the legality of lying about your age in
this kind of situation according to a
few lawyers I spoke to specialize in
eSports but first we need to figure out
how this whole situation started in
matey fou who is arguably the biggest
streamer in the world currently sued
faze clan the organization to which he's
been signed since 2018 now if you
haven't seen our two previous explainer
videos on this topic I highly recommend
you pause this open a new tab and watch
those because it's a complicated issue
and there's a lot of [ __ ] and drama
out there to cut through anyway is a
fairly minor part of that tfoo lawsuit
no pun intended in this case allege that
faze clan had actively recruited and
attempted to quote exploit at least one
artist who is a minor that's the first
mention of this in the lawsuit later on
it expands a little bit saying quote
faze clan has not only lied about the
minors age but has also pressured the
minor and his family to do so such
conduct by faze clan was in violation of
labour code 1700 0.36 so what does that
actually mean well section seventeen
hundred point three six of the
California Labor Code under division two
article three states that quote no
talent agency shall accept any
application for employment made by or on
behalf of a minor now according to
California's law and Labor Code a minor
is defined as anyone who's under 18
essentially now nowhere in the Tipu
lawsuit is this minor that they refer to
actually named but it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to figure out who
they're talking about
on March 22nd less than a month before
tea boos lawsuit would be filed faze
clan announced the signing of hi sky
their youngest member to date at the
apparent age of 13 now 13 is a key
number here guys because it is the
minimum age required by twitch to stream
on their platform and to participate in
a lot of Fortnight events like the
fortnight World Cup those are two things
that faze clan would very much like hi
sky to do now hi sky himself seems
pretty awesome and it's obvious why faze
clan would want to sign this guy no
matter his age the description on his
introduction video on Face clans YouTube
channel simply says it's hard not to
love this kid and it's true he seems
like a genuine humble young
man he's very ambitious he talks about
streaming 12 hours a day he talks about
the growth of his Instagram followers
definitely a guy you'd want under your
umbrella if you're somebody like faze
clan now when I was this age I was just
trying to find somebody who had pokemon
red so I could trade them and get a
cycler now here's where the trouble
starts on May 28th a report by eSports
website up comer claimed to have proof
that high sky was not 13 and was in fact
11 years old when faze clan signed him
and is now 12 years old the post
verifies this by doing some digging into
old social media posts made by his
parents that were originally in their
native Romanian language following that
On June 5th high skies twitch account
was suspended twitch did not put out a
statement after suspending his account
and we tried to reach out to them for
comment and have not received that yet
however the timing tells it all and it
seems abundantly clear that his account
suspension is probably connected to the
fact that he is underage the twitch
Terms of Service are pretty clear here
saying quote the twitch services are not
available to persons under the age of 13
and quote we also reached out to faze
and epic for comment on the high sky
situation and at such time that they or
twitch gets back to us we will update
you
now speaking of updates the latest one
on high sky himself is thankfully a
positive one he is back and he is
streaming but not on twitch on YouTube
during his youtube stream he apologized
for lying about his age and confirmed
that he was 12 years old family likes it
that I can fulfill my dream of being
human my dream for a long time and I
worked through like a year and a half
for it I'll say
and it held me back and I just couldn't
wait to Louise I finally got her off my
chest now I have been following this
case since the lawsuit broke last month
and I have to say of everybody involved
tangentially or not organizations
individuals high skies Communications to
the public on this have been the best
and that includes faze clan and some of
their executives and T foo and everybody
else involved and he's 12 years old now
it's worth noting here that in YouTube's
Terms of Service which are pretty murky
they do appear to prohibit you from
using the service if you're under the
age of 13 for example in their Terms of
Service there is a line that says quote
in any case you affirm that you are over
the age of 13 as the service is not
intended for children under 13 if you
are under 13 years of age then please do
not use this service
end quote that part seems pretty clear
but just before that there's a line that
says you affirm that you're either more
than 18 years of age which obviously
high skies not or an emancipated minor
or possesses legal parental or guardian
consent which he does so which
supersedes the other were not really
clear eSports pundit Rob slasher Breslau
says that high sky is able to circumvent
these Terms of Service at least in part
by having his mother participate in the
streams which clearly shows direct
parental supervision
now even though high sky is back and
streaming on YouTube with his mom and
it's adorable
he's still to our knowledge not able to
compete in at least most Fortnight
competitive events including the
fortnight World Cup until he's 13 anyway
now regardless of what happens with high
Sky's dreaming career over the next year
until he's 13 there is still the
question of what barring his admission
of falsifying his age will have on Teebs
lawsuit and the legality of faze clan
signing a minor to a contract now I
spoke to a number of lawyers
specializing in eSports about this one
of which was David Phillip Graham a
lawyer practicing in California who
deals with a lot of esports cases now if
you're a fighting game fan you probably
him better as ultra date right now now
good news for high sky here Ultra David
told me that faze clan employing him as
a minor is probably not actually illegal
in any way it's not necessarily illegal
if there is parental consent he told me
that if hi sky signed the contract
without parental or guardian consent he
could get out of it and void it pretty
easily through the legal system but
judging from how involved his family and
in particular his mother is in his
career I think it's pretty clear that he
does have parental Guardian consent to
sign that original faze clan document
now some states in the u.s. require a
judge to approve a contract of a minor
working in the entertainment and
athletic industries and we don't
actually know what state hi sky resides
him but if it were California for
example where faze clans base of
operations is he wouldn't need to go
through this process now all that having
being said this doesn't necessarily mean
there won't be any repercussions for
lying about his age I mean it can be a
big deal but it's not you know you're
not going to jail or anything so high
Skye's not gonna be behind bars anytime
soon obviously but the fact remains that
he did violate ethics Terms of Service
by competing under the age of 13 and
falsifying his age an epoch does have
rights to certain repercussions High's
guy has already won $5,000 in online
fortnight tournaments an epic can do
anything from a slap on the wrist
warning to taking away the money
entirely phase and hi sky have obviously
violated twitch and Epix rules and
regulations and we haven't seen his
contract his gamer agreement yet but if
his age happens to be falsified in that
well you don't need to have passed the
bar to know that that's gonna be a
problem
highs guys said in his first ever video
appearing on phase claims YouTube page
never give up on anything and it looks
like he's taking his own advice this
whole situation has to be pretty scary
if you're a guy his age but he's got the
talent and the charisma to make it far
in this streaming and game
world and I hope we see more of him in
the future to quote hi sky himself until
he turns 13 phase the budget also use
code I Skagen thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Applause]
[Music]